we got info reports Hassan and the
cartel
Terror itself all over the globe
we've never seen activity on this scale
before
me but we have each other the world is a
vampire
coming back
[Music]
to extraction
enemies above drill charge
you're gonna be okay
hostage secure
the world is
behind us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ER now and get early access to the open
beta
and there we go Call of Duty fans the
trailer so nice we ran it twice it is
all there everything that makes this
franchise so so special we are
incredibly excited to be here today and
after that quite frankly how can you not
be my name is Miles Ross and I am so
excited to truly be here with a few of
the members of the infinity war team who
are bringing Modern Warfare 2 to life
guys we have 200 of our friends behind
us who are going to be playing and
streaming shortly but before that we
also have Stephanie snow director of
communications for Infinity Ward as well
as Joseph over there Jeff Smith
multiplayer design directors here at
Infinity Ward guys first off
oh how are things evolving uh from
Modern Warfare 2019 I mean let's start
high level because there's a lot to get
through today guys you saw that trailer
let's go with the philosophy stuff let's
stay high level what went into the
creation of the game you said it
precisely there is so much this game has
just so much content it's got something
for everyone and it's really been the
result of three years of hard work
um at IW and our partners across all of
the Activision Studios and so much of
that work started with you guys at home
the community the fans our creators here
and that conversation and feedback from
2019 is really been a core piece of what
Modern Warfare 2 is and it's a dialogue
that we hope to uh you know continue
especially here today
well we've got so much in store with
this MP experience and um people like
Jeff and Joe here who I am honored to
work with and their experience on this
franchise we're in good hands
indeed okay so Jeff um well I don't know
where to start anymore uh let's uh let's
set up what Modern Warfare 2 multiplayer
is is all about uh let's stay high level
for now because there's a lot of details
friends juicy details sure I mean you
know when you come into making a sequel
it can be kind of tricky you know um
what do you keep from the previous game
uh what do you get rid of and where can
you add new things in and not mess up
this kind of nicely balanced ecosystem
that we had and so we came up with a few
uh methods one of them being player
behaviors and I say behaviors
um and not uh play Styles I think a lot
of people will say play Styles but that
can kind of change during a match but
behaviors are more ingrained in how
players play and we just put them into
three big groups we call them rushers
which are just aggressive players they
just want to find the action and go and
then we have Sentinels and these are
defensive players they want to just kind
of hold down a building maybe keep a
little OverWatch and then we have
stalkers which are reactive and they
kind of hang back and try to read the
field and read where spawns are and
really we just kind of use these as
filters to keep us honest with the
content that we're making so they're
making enough toys and equipment for
players to be successful playing our
game
that sounds like a lot of fun Stephanie
what are some of the new features coming
to multiplayer um some of the new stuff
that you're most excited to talk about
oh boy there are a ton of new features
to dive into with this game but um we
really pushed forward even the most
fundamental aspects of of what makes a
Call of Duty game with Modern Warfare 2
and it's been really amazing for me to
come on board this past year and see
these Innovations coming to life to hear
Jeff jump into you know breaking down
the 1v1 and personally for me uh water
or water I've seen the memes we love
water it's really hard to make in games
um with the Aquatic combat some of the
things you're able to do with vehicles
in the water I think that level of
immersion is really going to speak to
fans and has been something that I've
really enjoyed playing the last uh last
couple months aquatic combat Steph loves
to swim um Joe can we can we go into
some details about our water-based
adventures in MW2 yeah I mean last game
we really wanted to add water and we
knew we didn't have time right so in
verdance we froze the rivers and we made
the outskirts just to kill trigger in
this game as soon as we started Modern
Warfare 2 we leaned into water both
visually beautiful caustics there's
waves with white caps but we also have
the gameplay side there's unique
ballistics underwater you only can use
certain weapons underwater your pistol
is your weapon underwater otherwise you
can't use your primary weapons but it's
also a nice cover or evasion mechanic if
you're getting shot at you can dive into
the water and as you get deeper it gets
murkier like the farther you are from
something you can't see it and so it's
been super fun for us to dig into water
and really Flex on what water could be
in Call of Duty and you saw the boats
and the mine that floats and every piece
of equipment yeah I love it filtered
like how does it work through water like
we had to look at everything in the game
and say how does it work in water what's
the best version our vehicles will just
slowly submerge yeah really wood instead
of blinking out yeah I have a lot of
details the behaviors are awesome oh my
god well I cannot wait to uh can't quite
wait to literally dip my toes into those
Wars but guys let's not forget about
your ground in the air like I mean what
else is going to be coming to the
movement system Joe what do we go well
you know last game we did Mount
um and we had slide and even though
we're a military shooter fluid movement
is super important to us so this game if
you saw in the trailer you can see here
on the video we have a new ledgehang
mechanic and that's essentially a high
mantle but instead of doing a high
mantle and throwing yourself up over
into combat you can now Peak if you have
a pistol you can pull that pistol out
and use that we also added a dive you
know last game we had the slide that
kept your gun up but we really wanted
players to have an option where if
they're getting shot at they don't know
where they're getting shot at they can
get down get out of fire the the other
really cool thing is it Dives just high
enough to let you get through a window
and so if you throw a grenade up into a
building Second Story often you'll see
players you know like rats leaving a
ship diving out through the windows and
uh it's just another it's another option
for players in in combat yeah and all of
these Dynamic movements mean you can
interact with vehicles specifically in a
very cool way I'm Gonna Save uh some of
that some of that gas for when we get to
war zone 2.0 but uh it's a really
exciting all right vehicle details to
come uh but now guys let's talk about
equipment obviously called you crazy
sandbox a lot of cool toys to play with
uh Joe what are some of the new Dynamite
new items that we're going to be
throwing at each other and equipping and
using in all sorts in the next game I
mean you saw some cool stuff in the
trailer you saw that drill charge you
saw the shock stick um one of the other
cool ones you saw is the inflatable
decoy and this is a mine that you can
throw out and it basically sits there
and if the player gets close to it it
auto deploys and uh basically inflates
like a car airbag going off and it faces
the person that triggered it and so it's
a great distraction technique you can
honestly fire it off with a with a
clacker if you want to control when it
goes off you can throw it in water and
here you just saw the the DDOS we added
all this equipment into this game and
the DDOS is our kind of answer of like
hey I'm going to breach this building I
want to go clean house but I don't want
to do deal with all the [ __ ] inside so
I'm gonna hit the DDOS boom it's gonna
shut down everything I can move in yeah
and clear that room
um you saw the heartbeat sensor is back
it's got a new look but it also has a
battery as a balancing mechanic so you
can't use it indefinitely in war zone
um and there's I mean there's this
attack cam too yeah which to me is
um my personal favorite you can put out
a lot of them and even you can patch
into your teammates so you can it gets a
little crazy yeah kind of like a sticky
GoPro but will actually Mark your
enemies for um your team yeah so it's
it's I expect to see a lot of fun
there's so many things so many toys and
new tools that we're like we just want
players to get in and play with I think
there's something like 13 field upgrades
you know between Warzone and core and P
and it's it's pretty awesome oh my God
until they all get DDOS huh all this
talk about equipment uh it reminds me I
mean that's one element to look at now
but we've also got gunsmith brand new
gunsmith uh guys what can you tell me
about it and and how will it change the
way that we you know level our weapons
and manage them I mean what's going on
there yeah so the new gunsmith allows
players to build out their weapons more
smoothly than ever before we we put out
some videos yesterday for the Intel drop
I hope people dig into those if you want
a better look at gunsmith 2.0 but we're
really looking at unprecedented
opportunities for weapon customization
in the new weapon platforming will
actually allow players to unlock
Universal attachments through cross
progression so we saw a lot of really
positive feedback from the community
yesterday this is sort of intended to
you know decrease the grind you're no
longer unlocking every single attachment
for every single weapon there will be
some shared attachments through
progression and I'm really excited to
see the streamers and the content
creators jump into this today I know I
know we all love the gun bench from 2019
so it's exciting
it does sound amazing uh so we've been
hearing a little bit about weapon
platforms and shared attachments is very
very cool stuff can you dive into those
details though Jeremy what can we expect
yeah I can add a little bit of what to
what Stephanie said um we had this
Vision last game with gunsmith and we
were like okay what if you could take an
assault rifle and you could make it in
SMG and that was our driving kind of
like motivator for that system and we
kind of hit that we you could you could
take it functionally through attachments
with the weapon named wooden change and
we couldn't change the receiver and
really that's the key thing this game is
you can go into gunsmith you can set up
an AK-47 assault rifle with a thermal
optic with a suppressor with a grip then
you say you know what I want to change
up the play style of this gun you can
swap out the receiver to the ak-74u make
it an SMG but you can keep that optic
that suppressor that grip they all come
with and to what Stephanie said we have
shared attachments Within These
platforms we have branching progression
you unlock those guns by playing with
other guns and then we have shared
attachments across all guns and it's all
to hit this vision of I'm building up an
arsenal of weapons and an arsenal of
attachments I'm sitting down on my gun
bench and I'm gonna make the perfect
weapon for me I think the made the
simplest way to think about it is is a
gun tree and each time uh you hit a
branch that's a receiver and they and
they grow out of that yeah yeah and
that's you know you know we ground that
in reality they're a functionally
receiver you know is is based in that
changing the weapon type and I think it
provides a really seamless experience
for players looking to build out the
perfect weapon for a multitude of play
Styles so you're going to be able to
jump into that platform and customize
however you want for you know
situational combat and um you're
actually going to see the fjx cinder
weapon vault in action today which is
the entirely unlocked Platform One the
M4 the mic for the weapon vault
maintains its aesthetic properties
across all corresponding attachments so
we've heard you talk about the
frankenprint this is our answer it's an
extremely rare
um this is a huge you know project for
for our teams to design these but
um it is the Ultimate Weapon blueprint
and even better you can unlock the
entire Cinder weapon Vault with default
edition of Modern Warfare 2.
available in the beta so we can rock
with that thing all weekend long okay so
gunsmith looks incredible uh okay I'm
excited I cannot wait to get into this
one soon our streamers are going to get
into this one soon as well but first
guys we need to hear about maps and
modes we've got our tools to play with
equipment weapons maps and modes though
let's get into this one let's get into
uh the design team you know the
philosophy I suppose behind building out
Maps that's what Jeff this is for you
um yeah you know right from the start we
knew we wanted to build a big another
big map
um not only for Battle Royale but also
for this other mode that we've been
working on for uh quite a long time
um I read about that on the internet ah
yes but you know when you lay out these
big Maps it's kind of a collection of
all these little pois these points of
interest and um within each of these
we've really fine-tuned that they can
play core large-scale core modes like
ground war
um and a bunch of others
um really well
and so you know stepping back from this
large map and looking at how much open
World sandboxy gameplay that we have we
looked back at our 6v6 maps and really
tried to refine and make them a tighter
experience to contrast all this big
world
um kind of exploratory gameplay so the
maps uh for 6v6 in comparison to the
last game they're just um a little bit
more straightforward a little bit more
refined and I think fans will really
enjoy how quick they play that sounds a
lot of diversity in those Maps as well a
lot of visual variety some colorful maps
in there and um they I think they feel
really clean guys you're moving me in
ways I didn't imagine to be moved today
excellent stuff I might hey
we've got some of the maps that we are
going to be seeing in MW2 starting with
one uh we've got a real fun one here
guys this is one of the aforementioned
battle maps uh Team can you give me some
details on sarif Bay
so serif Bay is this little fishing Town
um in the south coast of our big map and
it we picked this because it has such a
great mix of gameplay uh it's right on a
harbor so we get to show off all our
boats and our new amphibious
um
APC
um and you know swimming as we've
already said
um but what you get inside the town is
this really intense Urban combat with
all these tight little Alleyways and uh
all this great rooftop combat and mixed
with our ledgehang you get these really
cool parkour Combat Action happening
yeah I love how you describe the uh the
rooftops there on this map specifically
is like a separate ecosystem you can
kind of migrate that entire version go
up there and just hang out and fight
other snipers all right well that was
fantastic Jeff okay so that's one of our
larger Maps uh what about some of the
6v6 maps I think we have uh we have some
footage of one of the new maps that
we're going to be seeing today uh named
Mercado Las Almas uh do you mind giving
us some details on this one sure
McCarter is um is a little Street Market
in a historic section in Mexico
um our story behind this is uh you know
the authorities have some Intel that
narcotics are being smuggled out of a
warehouse and they're going in trying to
find and seize them this map plays
really fast and a lot of action right
down that center lane
um the Mercado is a very dangerous uh
neck of the woods so watch out when
you're playing in the beta it plays fast
I cannot wait really can't wait looks
fantastic and again uh interesting to
see uh you know how that ties into
campaigns and whatnot all sorts of fun
and games ahead of us looks amazing
battle maps core maps 6v6 all this looks
fantastic uh but let's go back to modes
so we've seen some maps uh what about
the modes being played on Battle maps so
we will have the return of ground War uh
but we've got a new large-scale mode
that you've alluded to right let's talk
invasion
so invasion is it's a it's a big war map
it's like it's a big war TDM or we
affectionately call it the shipment of
ground war
um it's 20V 20 players but there's not
still 20 AI on each team uh AR coming in
fast roping they're coming out on medium
Birds
um and it's this High action mode it's
super fun but it's also really chill the
announcer is not barking at you he's not
saying like hey get to be you know
they're taking C but you can kind of
play it how you want to play it you sit
up on a rooftop and snipe you can grab a
shotgun and go room clearing if you push
too far into the enemy's base AI will
come hunt you but we've also been really
conscious of where we put Ai and
multiplayer
um we didn't put AI in killstreaks or
anything like that because we don't want
AI showing up in Search and Destroy we
don't want AI in Domination this mode
though however was built for AI and it's
a super fun mode can't wait for people
to try it kind of a funnier side you
know we took the name ground war from a
playlist in MW2 and that was just large
scale TDM and Dom and we kind of did the
Dom in the last game and now we're able
to add kind of the sandbox TDM and so
we're kind of completing the cycle of
that um that old playlist yeah this
large scale stuff looks amazing this
looks so so awesome man uh okay so what
about the new 6v6 modes just keep
dialing it in closer and closer Steph
what have we got yeah so we also have
two new 6v6 modes that you're going to
be seeing here displayed today
um and they will be in beta in prisoner
rescue and knockout prisoners okay let's
go into prison Rescue first joke
so prisoner rescue is an attack and
defend mode it's a round-based mode The
Defenders have two prisoners they're
kind of spread out and they need to keep
hold of them the goal of the attackers
is get to those prisoners pick them up
and carry them to x-fill when you pick
them up you enter What's called the
wounded carry where they're up on your
shoulders and you can't use your primary
weapons instead you have to use a pistol
if you brought it or you're just stuck
with fists but the way that we give the
attackers an advantage once they grab
that prisoner is they get a radar sweep
for their team so they can call out
where the Defenders are
um and the objective icon over the
prisoner goes away as soon as they scoop
them up so now the Defenders have to
basically rotate back to the x-fill and
set up defensive positions and it's this
heart-pounding adrenaline pushing like
mode once you grab that prisoner and try
and get them out that Hero Run yeah
definitely uh you know s and big S D
energy in this mode
um which I resonates with me my time in
Esports so this is my personal favorite
of the new ones and also sort of the
Strategic revive lives that happen there
is a revive mechanic and so you are able
to to pick up your teammates and I've
seen some pretty pretty wild comebacks
in our play test so far
it was a lot of fun we got to play a
tiny but yesterday was amazing
incredibly fun and I know the community
is going to love diving into it over the
next week okay I can hardly believe that
there's actually a lot more content to
get through but there's one more thing I
have to bring up I have the honor of
officially announcing the third person
view is finally coming to Modern Warfare
2. what are the details behind this one
we've got a little teaser on stage from
patro but what are the details yeah you
saw a little hint of it in the trailer
too um it's it's been a pet project for
us right we've always wanted to do third
person and all while we're working on
all this other stuff we've been kind of
lifting up and for doing third person in
each mode and the cool thing is that
it's a modifier on our game right we can
just turn on third person in the beta
will be playing it in hardpoint but we
want to try it post launch in s d we
want to try it in VR
um and we have you know camera work the
camera collision's been reworked uh it
handles tight spaces there's a water
camera there's an interior camera you
can feel the weapon shake when you're
firing with it and it's just we've put a
lot of work into it we're excited for
people to give it a try incredible I
can't wait to see what third person Cod
feels like in 20 22 sexy skins and
everything this is a lot of information
Steph like there's a ton here I tried to
warn you they were delivering a lot of
new features for you guys to try out
ahead of release
um and I said we were going to be bold
with this beta and we are but there's
even more to come at launch so this is
just a taste how is this just a taste
How can there be even more I mean we
haven't even got to Warzone okay okay so
what about uh this year's third mode so
I'm happy to say that special ops will
return as our third mode and we'll be
focused on two-player missions
asymmetrical in game design so think one
player on air support one player on the
ground and um I think the OG fans will
be really excited because we've looked
at you know some of the iconic Modern
Warfare missions like OverWatch and and
really tried to implement some of those
themes into the design so uh we'll be
talking more about special ops in the uh
in the months to come Steph you're
saying I should be looking now for a
special ops partner sitting right next
to you yes you are indeed well I'm all
set then Stephanie I do believe we have
one more uh surprise for PlayStation
players out there what's that indeed we
do let's uh roll the clip
empty-handed I was born
empty-handed
blade or bullet fist
spear stone for error these are merely
tools
I am the one to fear
take miles ISO
fix your mic PlayStation players will
receive an exclusive operator only Oni
is a warrior and gun for hire descended
from centuries-old Samurai Clan and torn
between country and family just like me
this is such an awesome looking operator
guys only is going to be playable on day
one for all who pre-ordered through the
PlayStation store plus he comes with a
high level weapon boot blueprint
playable in multiplayer and Warzone 2.0
Steph badass Oni is awesome I myself am
a PlayStation player and so I will be
locking becoming Oni main day one for
this game um and it's been really
awesome to see our narrative team
building out his lore really bringing
this operator to life with the creation
of his backstory his motives and I think
um the art team absolutely crushed it
with this skin he is
so so cool looking all right so we keep
talking about all the uh the things that
you know we have to look forward to but
um we are missing quite a big one here
we're missing the start of the beta so
for anyone who wants to get an early
first hand look at Modern Warfare 2. and
trust me you definitely want to it is
immediately available around the corner
for PlayStation players who pre-order
any version early access to the open
Beta starts tomorrow so make sure you
are preloading right now now also check
out your screens since here's exactly
when you can play the beta on your
platform of choice but don't forget
friends it's also definitely worth
noting that if you pre-order the Vault
edition of Modern Warfare 2 you get to
use the red team one for one operator
pack and the fjx cinder weapon vault in
the beta in addition to being able to
earn in-game rewards for playing all
sorts of cool swag and don't forget that
if you digitally pre-order model Fair 2
you also get up to a week early of
campaign access so it campaign a week
early alright folks I hope you enjoyed
that first look at Modern Warfare 2's
multiplayer we promise it was coming up
and now the wait is over it is time to
talk about Warzone 2.0 we got a glimpse
of some Warzone 2.0 in the multiplayer
multiplayer reveal trailer earlier today
and it does look awesome however we need
some true experts to help out back at
the desk here we have got Stephanie
Stone Josie cook is joining us but of
course welcome Jack O'Hara game director
at Infinity Ward Joe how are we feeling
we're running a party here I mean this
is uh this is a lot we need to know
everything Warzone 2.0 Stephanie the
world cannot wait it it feels crazy for
me to be up here revealing war zone 2.0
I ended up at IW as a fan of the game
and so this moment is absolutely bananas
for me but Warzone 2.0 is everything
that we loved about the original war
zone right where it it's based on the
same experience that we all had that
that fund all of those moments and it's
a it's a return to Shared Tech Across
the Universe for Modern Warfare 2 and
that's going to create a really
streamlined player experience and um I
think the key innovations that we
discussed for multiplayer those all all
exist across Warzone 2.0 as well so
we're bringing it back it's all
connected it's the same world and I
think the players are going to love it
oh my good God real excited about this
one uh again there's a lot in this one
Jack uh where do we go from here so MW2
and wasn't to have been developed side
by side since the beginning right since
we started down this road and they're
part of the same universe like Stephanie
said they share the same mechanics the
same weaponry and even more than that
but the centerpiece of all this of
course is a new map that we've been
working on since 2020 with teams across
the globe it brings together our
philosophies on map design it brings
together new technologies in order to do
it and lots and lots of artwork to make
it happen and we've learned so much from
players experiencing verdansk and
playing in for dance over the first few
years of Warzone and we're really
excited then for them to land in Al
mazara with their squad there's a wide
variety of points of interest for
players to explore in this map and we're
really looking forward to seeing
everybody in there oh here we go brand
new map to explore and Traverse I cannot
wait Stephanie let's take a look that's
right miles welcome
to El mazara this is our new map for
Warzone 2 .0 it is a really interesting
mix of geography it is expansive desert
settings with a mix of industrial areas
towns a city and of course water it
looks way better on this screen than it
did on Twitter
but you're gonna find a lot of really
cool elevation Rocky Peaks cave
Subterranean spaces this map is
beautiful and it's actually the biggest
VR map that we've ever made and I am so
excited for all of our streamers here to
jump into almazwell later today it's
huge look at the size of that thing uh
okay so that was a big picture and it's
a great way to see it from a sort of
top-down layout but uh let's take a
better look at some of these points of
interest
so when we set out to create these
spaces the team Works to make it feel
like a real space right so that there's
infrastructure in between all the
different what we call points of
interest along the map and if you're
paying attention you might even see a
few that seem pretty familiar out there
as well
um and so as the team Works through
these they're trying to find some
variety on each point of interest to
make them then something that the
players will want to drop in and get the
particularity of that single point of
interest and find the place that they
want to drop and where they want to play
whether it be a high elevation
Observatory at the center of the map
whether it be the big city that's up the
top right and whether they want to
explore that or whether they want to
work in some of our pois where we have
water intersecting with with geometry
here so we have in this one that looks
familiar
and there's a river system that goes
through all of this so you'll be able to
catch in a boat and drive between the
different pois and here's one of our
favorites sour Village which is that's
my favorite collectively called sunken
town I mean I love to swim so you find
me there absolutely um I'm curious what
you guys think Jack and Joe on what the
hot Drop will be today right we've been
talking about this last couple days this
is our first time seeing other people
who are not us play Warzone 2.0 and so
I'm just very curious where you think
everyone's gonna immediately drop today
I I think some people are going to drop
to Observatory just to go go back to
home you know they're coming home it's
always nice you're moving through the
map and you kind of hit a spot and
you're like wait uh I've been here
I have all these flashbacks oh yeah
there's a lot of nuggets in there for
some old uh yeah I'll say Corey I think
that's gonna pop off I think people will
land around the edge so they stay in as
long as possible in this match but we
have some news for our edge of the map
players coming up all right guys well
the map looks absolutely gorgeous and I
can't wait to watch our streams here uh
drop in early in an alpha build later on
today okay so moving on to the gameplay
uh we've got this beautiful space to
play in how do all of these multiplayer
elements we've talked about a little bit
earlier how do they fit into Warzone 200
know I mean that super simple answer is
all the stuff we talked about in
multiplayer the stuff you saw in the
multiplayer trailer that's all in
Warzone right it's all integrated so
that tactical camera Works in Warzone
that Decoy mind works in lawyers on like
it's all that's been built from the
ground up for both
the slide the dive the water like
more swimming yeah
this is a great taste of some of the
Water Combat
I can't wait to go full Captain Mill you
know Apocalypse Now coming out of the
war and knifing people I mean this just
looks yeah the rendering team made some
work so you come out you're looking all
wet yeah you see the caustics on the
bottom I'm not even sure what color
sticks are I have no idea but it sounds
great and it looks incredible you can
see the armored Patrol boat coming by
there with its two turrets it's there's
some cool stuff so I'm glad you brought
vehicles uh so have you touched on
vehicles a little bit earlier what can
we talk about uh you know we see boats
with tanks we've seen all sorts of track
what we got so we've implemented a new
physics and handling model for the
vehicles so some vehicles are heavier
some will slide more have more traction
or less traction and as you're driving
them around and you're encountering them
and other squads are playing with them
you can choose to shoot off the tires to
kind of impact their handling you can
have them they react to explosive
differently based on their weight so if
you're in a heavy armored 4x4 and get
hit by an RPG it's going to kind of
Bounce a little bit but not quite take
the hit as a small sedan you can also
choose with your squad to be rolling
into appeal why and somebody jumps out
on the roof somebody leans out the
window and suddenly you got yourself a
lot of Firepower driving into the POI of
course that vehicle needs to survive for
quite some time in the map if you want
to keep using it to go from point to
point and vehicles will run out of gas
or at least most of them will will run
out of gas and then you can bring them
to a gas station to fill them up if your
tire has been blown up you can get out
and repair it or you can bring it to a
gas station to get repaired as well and
of course we've got you know water
Vehicles we've got a small boat we've
got the boat that Joe mentioned with the
turret turret at the back so you can
have that little moment cruising up the
river with your whole Squad ready to
rumble so yeah there is so much love
that's gone into these videos the
coolest vehicle the coolest vehicle
massive helicopter that you can fly
around that's a big platform with three
doors and people play you can move a
whole Squad through the map what wreak
havoc it is so cool oh my God I think
the fact that you can lean out of the
window you know grab your teammates Pile
in a vehicle actually you know engage in
battle from the window leaning out too
somebody blew off your door
that does complicate things so you get
PTSD from uh Joe killing me many times
in our play test well I hope the gas
prices in our mazara okay I thought
there's a lot going on in Warzone 2.0
and uh my head is quite frankly spinning
uh what are the massive changes um have
we got in store because it feels like
there's a there's so much has changed is
it still a gulag do we still have
circles is it still gas I know there are
guns but do we shoot them what's
happening what do you want to jump into
first oh exactly we've made some pretty
exponents of War Zone 2.0 to continue
providing players with both a dynamic
and rewarding VR experience but Warzone
2.0 you're going to hear it over and
over again today it's about fun this is
about playing with your friends having
fun you know Friends new and old maybe
you're making them a game and I think
one particular feature that I cannot
wait to see streamers engage with will
be our prox chat yes so it's coming it
will be in Warzone and I I there is
going to be some amazing clips
but um
I think Joe can uh tell us a little bit
more about looting and about 2.0 I'm
listening to them
um you know in looting in Warzone 2.0 we
still have the humming crates you know
you can still travel around and listen
for those who still have the loose Loot
on the ground but we wanted to add a
layer of learnability and and logic to
our looting right so if you if you're
outside if you're a little kid you fall
down you hurt your knee and your mom's
gonna go inside go to the medicine
cabinet and get you something to a
Band-Aid Neosporin whatever so that's
our looting if you're you need health
items you can hit a bathroom in a
building and there'll be a medicine
cabinet you can open it up
um if you want to get Loadout items
there are these hidden caches throughout
in between the pois that are in ground
and you can memorize where they are
because they're always there so you can
kind of start to develop these paths
through the map of how you Loot and
there's this logic applied to looting
you know you can find toolboxes that'll
have grenades and things in them
um and you find these other crates that
are kind of like it's as if the the
military that occupied this space came
through and dropped off military items
those crates are always there so you can
always have this reliable layer to
looting incredible this sounds really
exciting we go on a road trip through
our mother and quite literally like have
a route we plan hit the gas station yeah
yeah pick up snacks pick up ammo and all
sorts Okay cool so what about Circle
mechanics I mean this is obviously a
huge component of br's check yeah I mean
the circle's been a staple of br's it's
been really hard to move away from it so
we kind of talked about what could we do
to mix things up with the circle so
we've got this new mechanic where the
circle can actually split almost like a
cell split into two three or even four
circles and then those circles kind of
close down and what it does is it
segregates teams and you have these
micro battles in those circles and a
certain point you're like okay we've
cleared out our Circle we think we're
good and then those circles merge they
come back together and you know you have
this very directed Fight of like as the
circle's moving you're like gearing up
in buildings you're like here we go it's
about to kick off and as soon as those
circles hit you have that final fight so
it's another kind of like twist in the
gameplay that we feel like is a cool
world event that would happen like the
circle splitting we need to do X crazy
get in the car we're going now go all
right so apart from apart from circus
playing uh what about the gulag is that
still around I mean it's so much change
man I mean I'm ready for it but Joe what
do we got the gulag you know we've been
experimenting with we've tried some
crazy things
but the the current version of the gulag
that we we have running right now we're
exciting people to play is you're not in
there alone you actually have this
temporary alliance with another opponent
in the map and you guys you have to work
together and if you can defeat the other
team you can get out and after that you
guys are enemies again but for that
moment it's like all right we need each
other let's do this you use the
proximity chat to talk to each other and
the other thing we've been playing
around with is you may see a little bit
of an AI presence in the gulag so you
kind of you have to be on your toes like
you're working with an enemy there might
be an AI here you're picking up weapons
um we're excited for people to try it
yeah we're gonna get feedback today too
and and like Joe said we've been through
some pretty wild iterations of the gulag
which I will not reveal here but uh
there's there's a lot in store
there certainly is a lot in store um
Jack I have heard uh of A New Concept
coming to Warzone 2.0 called strongholds
that will include AI that may impact how
players get their weapons Etc uh can you
clue me into what that's all about and
if it's even true absolutely um so
strongholds are reinforced buildings
that they are the AIS are occupying
inside Al mazara in BR and the players
can choose whether or not they want to
engage with them and assault them to get
core rewards including free Loadout
items which is one of the new ways that
we're adding for players to get their
hands on their best weapon we've worked
really hard to bring AI into at scale
into war zone two and you're going to
encounter them in multiple modes in
different way in BR specifically they're
in these strongholds and if you get to a
stronghold you can find the location of
a black side which is going to have even
cooler stuff in it and you can fight
your way from one to the next but in
other modes you're going to find the AI
occupying large portions of the map and
just kind of protecting different pois
in different ways unreal Okay so we've
all heard the rumors that Zone 2.0 is
going to have some very very interesting
new modes uh would you care to confirm
or deny Stephanie Snowden it's finally
time I have read about some new modes on
the internet recently but one of the
most exciting things about Warzone 2.0
is confirmation that an all-new sandbox
experience is coming at launch I am
happy to announce DMZ Call of Duty's
extraction mode will arrive with Warzone
2.0 AT launch later this year I play DMZ
for the very first time on my first day
at IW and to this day playing it
non-stop the possibilities with this
game mode below my mind so DMZ I can
also confirm the DMZ is real so we're
not gonna go into depth on it today
because we do have to keep some stuff in
reserve what I can tell you though is
we've created a rich sandbox where you
can Define your own win condition you
infiltrate al-mazra you accomplish your
goals and then you decide to extract
when the time is right it is played
across the whole map and the AI is
occupying large sections of the map and
they are lethal opponents and they do
command your respect you have to watch
out for them you have to work with your
team they Patrol areas they occupy
strongholds and they'll reinforce based
on players actions
and then on top of all this you can
choose which Mission you want to
accomplish or you can chase after a
variety of activities in the world and
you can play this differently depending
on your playstyle you can go loud like I
always do you can go quiet or you can
hunt other players or avoid them
entirely or you could just decide hey
I'm going to explore the secrets of Al
mazara and see what's there loot up
x-fill it's it's totally up to player
choice there and um I'm really excited
about the full scale of what we're
delivering for this chapter and we want
players to have an amazing experience in
war zone 2.0 we've been listening to the
conversations in the community
specifically around small Maps Ricochet
anti-cheat ranked play and Beyond and
trust me although we're touching on some
of the core updates to the overall
Warzone 2.0 experience today and mostly
focusing on BR there will be more news
to share over the coming months this is
only the beginning for Warzone 2.0 okay
I need Warzone 2.0 and DMZ in my life
ASAP Stephanie Wynn Warzone 2.0 will be
free to play for everyone on November
16th with the start of season one across
Modern Warfare 2. mark your calendars
that's about two weeks uh after
after Modern Warfare 2 launches
um and we had a 125 million players in
the original war zone and I cannot wait
to see all of you and hopefully more of
you in almazura for this experience
and you will have a chance to see a
wasn't two Battle Royale Alpha play test
happening right here behind us very very
soon yeah the streams are hot to trot
they're wearing a go uh we will see all
of you in an almaza November 16th but
don't go anywhere just yet stick around
because when we come back you'll see
just what Warzone looks like when it's
built up from the ground for mobile
you're not going to want to miss this I
promise then after that we have live
gameplay coming at us with all of our
friends set up across the each and every
Modern Warfare 2 multiplayer we've got
Warzone 2.0 without Royale we've got
Warzone mobile it's all Happening Here
ladies and gentlemen don't go too far
foreign
foreign
foreign
what a jam-packed day we've had here so
far we got war zone 2.0 and Modern
Warfare 2 already good to go but finally
we're hitting something new here coming
into Mobile we got Warzone mobile 2 here
for you it's me beef mommy and I
couldn't be more excited to be here with
none other than Chris Plummer and Chris
what do you have for us today that's
right today we are proud to introduce
Call of Duty Warzone mobile this is the
real thing and it's on your phone for
the first time ever you can drop in the
Call of Duty war zone from wherever life
takes you let me quickly point out the
gameplay you're seeing today is still
Alpha so it's only going to get better
and for Warzone fans you will recognize
this drop sequence right away I mean
honestly it just gives me so much
Nostalgia but wait a minute Chris is
that the legendary verdesk
you know this is where Warzone gameplay
was born and we're bringing the
legendary for dance map to mobile for
the very first time from its Hallmark
Vistas
and these dense urban areas they're just
so much fun to play in Wide Open Fields
ready for battle an intimate Close
Quarters combat environments there's so
much Variety in verdance it's famous for
good reason teaming with fan favorite
locations like Boneyard
and Superstore
even TV station well I'm getting classic
Call of Duty war zone flashbacks here
can you tell us more about the gameplay
or you know what maybe just give me your
phone real quick maybe I can see for
myself no you know the team has a
passion for delivering the most
authentic Call of Duty experience
possible for mobile devices from the way
you aim and move to the weapon handling
and the control responsiveness all these
critical little details combined to make
Call of Duty Warzone mobile feel Best in
Class we've made sure that the physics
the feedback the sights and sounds all
those essential little touches are
smooth and accurate it's about creating
an experience that's so true to form you
can imagine feeling that dirt
compressing under the soles of your
boots with every move or imagine those
tiny shock waves of recoil moving
through your entire body with every shot
and Warzone mobile these are the kind of
details that we care about that make the
combat feel airtight and authentic that
makes me really emotional Chris and you
know it sounds like everyone's paying
attention to detail and it's finally
paying off now when I think of Call of
Duty Warzone I think about strategy
absolutely there's a lot more going on
than pure gun plays for example when
you're out there exploring a map and
evading the gas Circle collapse you can
try to sneak up on another player and
pull off a finishing move it's like
ultimate bragging rights and if you're
feeling more strategic you and your
squad making complete contracts use that
cash and buy stations there's a ton of
variety there
including lots of different abilities
like bringing back or falling Squad made
now that contract economy it adds a ton
of depth and strategy through risk and
reward I really like that you brought
that up because if you're talking about
risk and reward I think about the kill
streaks I think about the gulag are they
going to be there too
yes everything you come to expect from
Warzone is going to be there especially
kill streaks this means you can deploy
your big stick of choice like you know a
Precision airstrike you might be able to
wipe out an entire Squad with it so not
so fortunate for them but they're not
necessarily down for an account either
because we have the gulag so here
players can fight for a second chance
so when you go down you get the fight
101 with another down player and you can
earn your way back into battle
this is how Warzone mobile plays out on
a truly massive scale unlike anything
we've ever played on mobile before
this reason we're pushing way past the
envelope on high player counts to make
sure each match is jam-packed with our
signature style of combat so we are
supporting up to 120 Live players in the
single match
hold on did you just say okay
120 players or do you mean Bots because
it seems like in Battle Royale games on
mobile they're usually loaded up with
boring Bots
well we believe it's critically
important in a lot more fun to play with
real live Human opponents and that's our
Focus so for anyone who's tired of
playing with nothing but Bots we hear
you
we're talking up to 120 Rio players
ready to hunt you down with real human
skill and real human emotions that is
Call of Duty Warzone mobile and we we
hear you in the crowd everyone's excited
and absolutely it is huge and I don't
think there's a game on mobile that can
top that in terms of Real Player count
of course but how are you able to even
pull that off
we can support Real Player counts at
dramatically higher scale than we've
ever seen in other Battle Royale games
on mobile because Warzone mobile is
running on Advanced unified Call of Duty
technology this is the same share Tech
behind the console and PC versions of
Warzone 2.0 it gives us a ton of
advantages like these incredibly High
player accounts authentic Call of Duty
combat and gameplay systems and it opens
the door to a much more connected
experience across all platforms So when
you say more connected does that mean
that Warzone mobile will share content
and features that will be in the console
and PC version of Warzone 2.0 exactly
delivering a deeply connected experience
it's been a strategic pillar from the
beginning of development now we know
that your time is precious and your
investment in playing is now recognized
across Modern Warfare 2 war zone 2.0 and
Warzone mobile so wherever you're
playing Call of Duty it is time well
spent including on mobile
even your friends list and chat or
shared across platforms so you can stay
in touch with your friends whether
they're playing on Console or PC or
mobile wherever they choose to play I
mean that is so exciting I totally get
that now one of the coolest benefits of
having this kind of connectivity is that
Call of Duty Warzone mobile is loaded up
with the same authentic Call of Duty
weapons and operators you'll recognize
from Modern Warfare 2 and Warzone 2.0
and whatever you get from the battle
pass you will see it on Console or PC
it'll also be there on your mobile
device too and the other way around
works as well
I really love to hear that and as a
matter of fact I saw some of the same
weapons and operators being shown
earlier today in Call of Duty war zone
2.0 are you aiming to make it exactly
the same on all platforms you know
that's a great question it's a team's
incredibly excited about how deeply
connected and authentic experiences and
Call of Duty Warzone mobile and we'll
continue to adapt the best content and
features and Innovations created across
the franchise
but at the same time we recognize that
mobile is a very unique platform mobile
has its own flavor advantages and player
expectations
sounds like the game will be tied into
the Call of Duty franchise pretty nicely
and will there be mobile specific events
or content that is unique to Warzone
mobile
yes Above All Else the team is committed
to ensuring Warzone mobile is a
world-class mobile first experience
right down to its core
controls are a huge part of it it just
needs to feel natural on the device
intuitive and you know native to the
platform
a lot of it comes down to tuning and
this is why we are supporting
synchronous cross play between IOS and
Android platforms exclusively on mobile
and we're avoiding the imbalance that
comes with cross planes between mobile
devices and consoles or mobile to PC
this allows our teams to deliver the
best possible mobile gameplay experience
with a unified feel and by doing this we
don't need to compromise the tuning for
any platform this ensures a Level
Playing Field and more fun for everyone
now keeping those controls balanced for
all player types it's super important so
whether you're the hardest of hardcore
mobile Pros or maybe you're a console
first player that's sneaking in an extra
master in your lunch break even brand
new players to the franchise you need a
little help getting into the flow of the
game we are committed to providing the
most robust control options anywhere for
a pick up and play experience that's
accessible to all of our players I love
that accessibility and that means all my
friends can get in on the action for a
change but how do they sign up well it's
time to get your mobile devices ready
because I'm super excited to announce
it's starting right now you can
pre-register for your free download in
the Google Play Store
signing up means that you can be among
the first to play when a game launches
next year we look forward to seeing
everyone in Call of Duty Wars on mobile
ah with that being said
free Reg
hey guys Burke here and I am thrilled to
be one of the first to pre-register for
Call of Duty Warzone mobile and now you
can too scan the QR code at the bottom
of the screen to be among the first to
draw tell your friends because the more
pre-registrations we drive the more
rewards we can earn like special weapons
vinyls and ambulance plus if we reach
the top Milestone of 25 million
pre-registers we're going to unlock a
super cool secret reward you're not
going to want to miss what are you
waiting for sign up using the QR code
below
we are back it's Mouse here joined by
Maven alligator Neymar oh guys the
adults have left us alone on the desk
and now it's our time to have some fun I
don't know about you guys but uh okay
it's been a pretty late day so far yeah
where do we even start I mean dude
mobile bro it's a new era of Call of
Duty Mouse I've been addicted to Call of
Duty for over a decade you're telling me
I could be in the airport playing
Warzone now packing for dance that's lit
also El Mazda looks absolutely
incredible oh it's insane all right
there's no shortage of crazy stuff
coming away Ali I mean lay it on me
multiplayer for Wars for Modern Warfare
two insane it's incredible we actually
got to load up with some of the Players
yesterday you know a little bit of a
pre-test and loading into gunsmith 2.0
was actually so aesthetically pleasing
and I think everybody at home once they
also get their hands on it they're going
to love it just as much as we do here
truly uh Maven my good my good friend
you've played more Warzone than most
people on the Northern Hemisphere yeah
eight hours a day for years it feels
like it just seems fresh man the math
like everything about it triple circles
uh the Water the boats I mean obviously
kind of the proximity in my king for a
while there but they see some other
vehicles trying to blow them up instead
of booby traps and now you're telling me
I can do them and not only land but also
the sea I'm with it